folks valor it might be a new game but
we've seen plenty of incredible plays so
far it's a wood versus one now he spots
every spring the Hawks go to a Sunnah
and the ACE clutch coming in but today
we wanted to focus on a specific kind of
play those moments when one player faces
incredible odds and does the impossible
we're talking about clutches so here are
the top ten clutches in valor and so far
kicking off our list is an absolutely
disgusting eighths clutch from CS goes
Banda prodigy cornered in a post plant
situation at the twitch rivals valor and
launched tournament brats wasn't fazed
and despite being a 1v4 he delivered the
kind of performance that one would
expect from CS goes prodigal son
this little black player standing enemy
remaining valor n't is Brax his chance
to make a comeback and plays like this
prove that he's destined for greatness
clutching will defending a site is one
thing but it takes some huge stones to
clutch out a retake
which is why Wardell clutch on split
comes in at number 9 on our list where
did he go mostly cotton eye Joe has
nothing to do with it because Wardell
it's just putting on what I think his
best performance retaking a site is hard
especially when the enemy team knows
where you are
but Wardell was just insane enough to
attempt it last when ago Wardell misses
the option enough at this point you're
just gonna try to look for some exits
cuz you're fully blinded aftershock
cover sir sorry full flame coming
through as well he picks up the phantom
in the first headshot onto easy game and
actually he's gonna commit it to this
putting a smoke in the front of the site
here you still have a dark cloud moving
in at bar cover inside the main site
somehow that should have connect all he
does tonight finally with the ghost
tapping on the spike - does he have
enough time for the fuse once again
and he what a clutch from more joy
goodness Wardell masterfully isolated
each individual player and
systematically dismantled the defense
for a clean as [ __ ] retake and even
managed to kill the rays before she got
her altough talk about clutch taking the
number eight spot on our list is a
clutch from happy who proved that even
healers can pull off some insane
clutches we've seen it time and time
again happy consistently uses his own
wall for his own benefit and this time
it's a 1v3 clutch as a result during the
g2 valor an invitational team time who
dominated the first half of mind which
meant that happy was so far ahead that
he picard peeking over a smoke into a
1v3 clutch situation wasn't the worst
idea now it's all on to the stage but
it's happy who else would you want in
this scenario oh man they tried to put
up a wall you think that's gonna stop
them it never has in the past counter
wall coming out from happy who's using
the smoke that's down the dodge what's
coming towards them Happy's playing this
one masterfully using that wall boosting
up over the top there's happy this man
needs a team and he needs it stat look
at this replay using the smoke that the
opposition put down surprising
absolutely no one the human headshot
machines insane clutch on split takes a
number seven spot on our list
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
caught in a 1v4 scream used his big
brain to maneuver around the map and
systematically take out each player
dodging Ultimates
and nailing headshots in the process
sure they might not be his signature one
taps but come on he's still the headshot
machine boom
did you guys I don't know how we made
this it's a difficult man taking the
number six spot on our list is need
first and a player to reach a valor in
rank tens did do that thing's insane
tens is one of na s most impressive
players and this clip will show you
exactly why he's been getting so much
height over the last few months
what the [ __ ] dude dude that thing's
insane using nothing but a Marshall and
a judge tends completely decimated the
opposing team in a 1v5 that looked all
but lost now that's a clutch you knew it
was only a matter of time before he Co
made an appearance on this list and the
fact that he can clutch out around when
cheaters are trying to stop him is more
than worthy of our number five entry
this guy can literally see me through
the wall he's trying to pre-fire me and
I literally kill him as he's trying to
shoot me through a wall that's unwalled
more valor ins anti cheat software
doesn't catch every player and eco could
tell pretty quickly that he was playing
against a no-good hacker but that didn't
stop the former csgo pro from clutching
it out when it mattered most
this guy this guy can literally see me
through the wall he's trying to pre fire
me and I literally kill him as he's
trying to shoot me through a wall that's
on wall abort tap tap ace and yeah he
won the game to proving that good always
defeats evil taking the number four spot
on our list is the csgo goat simple
[Music]
now I think we all knew that simple
would take the Valor and pretty quickly
but this insane 1v3 with the OP is still
truly crazy especially when you consider
how easy he made it look if you blink
you might just miss our number three
play Cory securing an incredible 1v3
clutch with rays from fine showers Cory
is in the house up against sentinels at
valor and ignition series Cory was
caught in a one before situation with
only his gun and utility to play off of
but luckily that was all the young valor
and Pro needed they were not watching
that I'm a little surprised there Gaskin
almost as surprised as I am that Ponzi
is awake right now but Cory's gonna push
through showers does find one can he do
anything specially against the second
this could be something of magic does
have a grenade to work with now with
four lightning fast headshots Cory saved
the round for faze clan and secured a
nasty clip for his own personal
highlight reel take you the runner-up
spot on our list is this insane clutch
from Baum car that had everyone popping
off I was [ __ ] insane playing on Team
dragon during the g2 esports
invitational bomb car we left in a 1v4
scenario with kima existence approaching
from all angles and then he made a magic
C Mon C Mon 1ct to heaven DT to heaven
[Applause]
with his team popping off and leading
the map nine to three bombs are put down
one of the most memorable clutches and
probe a Lawrence so far and if you ask
us we think this one will have some
staying power is it really a surprise to
anyone that CS is resident clutch master
would take the top spot on this list
well if you are surprised then let us
introduce you to the play that truly
solidified hiko as one of valour inspect
all my god since Valerie
came out Eko has pulled off jaw-dropping
plays but this is one of his finest
[Music]
[Music]
dude dude oh my god put in a 1v4 with
little info Kiko went on the hunt
calculating exactly where the enemy
players were just like he used to do in
CS he kill destroyed the enemy team with
ease
all right folks that's our list if you
think we missed a play then let us know
in the comments and while you're down
there tell us if you want to see more
Valor and top tens and what topics you
want us to hit don't forget to sub to
the channel and make sure to head over
to twitch.tv slash the score eSports
because guess what we're streaming now
you've got to follow us to make sure you
never miss a stream thanks for watching
and we'll see you next week I can't [ __ ]
it I decided this I took a vacation
recently and I tried to play some
team-based games on my own I decide no
[ __ ] this I'm not interested in playing
these games unless I can play with four
other humans I was playing Bower it and
like one time I forgot I had the bomb
and didn't plan it for a second and for
the rest of the [ __ ] game one dude
was on my ass about it I can't wait to
get one of the [ __ ] League of Legends
fighting game comes out the riot
fighting game comes out I can't wait for
these [ __ ] to have to deal with
it to deal this ship from me but there
is going to be a [ __ ] moment where
one of these [ __ ] CS players or
League players
queue up and I'm gonna [ __ ] perfect
them and they're gonna call me a scrub
because I spammed the moves or whatever
I'm gonna report them for being [ __ ]